hey Batman I guess scarecrow gave you
the slip
you broke my wrist for nothing he's got
plans for you Batman Batman Arkham
Knight has finally come to store shelves
after a long delay that kind of made a
lot of people sad myself included
because not only am i a big Batman fan
I'm just a fan of good games and I've
liked each of the previous Arkham games
and although the gameplay of Arkham
origins was still fun I just wasn't
really that invested in the story of
that game I didn't find it very
interesting and so I was really excited
to find out that Rocksteady was
returning to make Batman Arkham Knight
and you know what it's also rated mature
that's interesting there's never been a
mature rated Batman game ever in fact
very rarely do comic book games ever
received that rating so the plot of this
game is that scarecrow has threatened to
release a toxin across the entire city
all of Gotham has been evacuated the
only people that remain in Gotham are
the police and criminals and Batman and
so immediately right off the bat you get
this really eerie sense that Gotham is
deserted filled with nothing but hate
kind of like the last 20 minutes of
Batman Begins where you just saw the
Scarecrow infecting the entire city and
everyone was just turning against each
other that's what this entire game feels
like in Kevin Conroy the voice from the
animated series has returned to voice
Batman which is just so great whenever
anyone asked me who my favorite Batman
voices are like as a Christian Bale is a
Michael Keaton I'm like no it's Kevin
Conroy and if they say who's Kevin
Conroy I'm like I'm not going to talk to
you anymore because it's Batman and of
course the most unique new thing about
this game is the fact that you can drive
the Batmobile you can actually get
inside the friggin Batmobile and tear
ass around Gotham there's also a battle
mode for the Batmobile where you turn
into this tank and face off against
various enemy drones and if you are
shooting at criminals who are on foot
you shoot these like rubber pellets so
you're still not killing people
technically although you're causing a
lot of damage now some people are really
not enjoying the Batmobile which I can
understand I fucking love it it's the
Batmobile and you get to drive it and
I have had no problems controlling it
some people are complaining about that
there's been some problems with a PC
port of the game I'm playing it on ps4
I've had no problems with it maybe it's
because I grew up playing a lot of
arcade racers as a kid and I'm just used
to that type of feel I don't know I've
had no problems with the Batmobile I
fucking love it
before I talk a bit about the story and
don't worry no spoilers let's talk about
the gameplay a little bit the combat
feels improved there's a lot more things
that Batman can do this time around
although it does involve a lot of button
mashing and there are times in this game
where it can get a little frustrating
because sometimes the militia just
overwhelms you scarecrows militia and
Arkham Knights militia and you die over
and over again you get that death screen
where somebody mocks you cuz you just
died it can get rather hard to deal with
let me just put it this way my wife was
downstairs I was upstairs playing the
game and she asked me if I was okay I
was like yeah I'm just really annoyed
with the Riddler right now hon I'm just
The Riddler keeps mocking me just just
let me play and that's one of the most
annoying aspects of this game is once
you actually beat the main story you
then have to do various things to get
the 100% ending including a lot of
Riddler challenges and a lot of Riddler
races and I like the Riddler challenges
you do on foot you're trying to rescue
Catwoman she's been in prison by the
Riddler she has this bomb necklace on
her and you have to do these various
tests of physics or weight or number
memorization things like that those are
a lot of fun you have to team up with
Catwoman to solve these things I love
those then there are these Riddler race
tracks with the Batmobile and I wanted
to claw my eyes out because not only do
they get unusually difficult but as you
fail or mess up on something the Riddler
continuously continuously antagonizes
you and I was like shut the fuck up
Riddler that's by far the most negative
I'm gonna get in this review because
that was really the only thing about
this game that bugged me the aspects of
getting all those little things to get
them 100% ending but not only is this a
really great Batman game it's a really
great Batman story I became enthralled
by the cinematics of this game the way
it was directed the way they turned the
tables on you sometimes through
scarecrows hallucinations you have to
interact these horrific
nightmare sequences towards the end that
just blew my mind the way they were
directed I really cannot talk enough
about how well the cinematics were
directed in this game and how
interesting the story is and how
invested I was actually getting in this
new Batman story it reminded me of the
best of the Batman animated series and
in some ways the story was like a great
mashup of the Dark Knight trilogy there
was the Batman Begins aspect with two
Scarecrow infecting the city and people
turning on each other
The Dark Knight has some influences
throughout the game in regards to
psychologically tormenting Batman and a
whole militia against the police aspect
of the Dark Knight Rises is also
included in Arkham Knight this game
takes some of the coolest story aspects
of the animated series in those three
films and makes a kick-ass story let's
talk briefly about the graphics because
they're absolutely stunning it's raining
the entire time throughout this game as
you tear through Gotham whether on the
Batmobile or you're gliding around as
Batman
it is breathtaking I experienced zero
framerate issues nothing I mean it was
just it was a perfect engine I had no
problems with the way this game
performed I know some people on PC or
having issues but on the ps4
I didn't encounter one glitch one error
nothing throughout my entire playthrough
however I do think there are probably
too many tank battles that being said
this is my favorite of the Arkham games
so far I love the story
I love the Batmobile I love Kevin Conroy
as Batman I love this psychological
torment of Batman that takes place in
this game don't want to spoil it for you
because I didn't know about it and it's
one of the best things in this game by
far I can't wait for you guys to
experience it because it blew my mind
and just to briefly talk about the
arkham knight because i don't want to
get into spoiler territory i thought he
was an excellent villain he was very
interesting i was always wondering like
is it who i think it is like and then it
was who i thought it was but i still
liked the fact that that went that way i
know some people aren't fans of the
eventual reveal I think it's awesome I
think it works in this game maybe not
necessarily in the comic book lore but
in this game it worked really well I
think the story elements the cinematics
of this game hooked
I mean when I grew up it was like
superman 64 batman dark tomorrow i mean
that that's the kind of superhero games
we had when i was a kid let's not take
it for granted they're making some
kick-ass freakin superhero games now and
i'm so glad i get to live in one of the
best time periods ever for the character
of batman I'm gonna give Batman Arkham
Knight a 9.5 out of 10 those extra
things you had to do with the Batmobile
and the Riddler kind of got on my nerves
but other than that guys I had a
freaking amazing time playing this game
and I want to give a big thank you to my
buddy Matthew a friend of mine who gave
me this really awesome Batman Arkham
Knight poster double sided thank you my
friend thank you very much also I want
to give another big thank you to the
fact that I actually have a sponsor for
this video and they contacted me and
they were nice enough to send me a
product and I'm very appreciative for
that and I want to thank them for
sponsoring this video because you know
what
it helps me pay my rent plain and simple
Harry's comm was started by two guys who
are very passionate about what they do
the shipping is always free and I have a
special offer to give my viewers a
discount code which is going to be the
word stuckman if you want to go to
harrys.com Harry's Truman set is just 15
bucks it includes the razor three blades
and your choice of Harry's shave cream
or foaming shave gel as an added bonus
you can get five bucks off your first
purchase with my code stuckman that's
right stuckman and get the entire
month's worth of shaving supplies for
just ten bucks and there's a link in the
description code for you if you would
like to experience that thank you very
much to Harry's for sponsoring my videos
it's a big help to me and thank you guys
for watching this review I love you you
guys are the best thank you so much as
always for watching and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
minute iced